this video is brought to you by
Squarespace
the premier or the one platform to build
your online presence the knavery follows
Scythian customs but one generation
before the advent of Darius's army they
happen to be driven from their country
by snakes for their land produced great
numbers of these and still more came
down on them from out of the desolation
on the north it may be that these people
are wizards for the Syrians and Greeks
settled in Cydia say that once a year
every one of the naeuri becomes a wolf
for a few days and changes back again to
his former shape those who tell this
tale do not convince me but they tell it
nonetheless and swear to its truth men
who are afflicted with the can therapy
go out at night and imitate wolves in
every way
spending time until daybreak among the
gravestones you will recognize that
someone is suffering from this by the
following symptoms they appear pale and
look weak
they have dry eyes and cannot cry you
may observe that their eyes are hollow
and their tongue is especially dry they
cannot really produce saliva they are
thus thirsty and in addition they have
wounded shins from scraping the ground
frequently these are the symptoms for
treatment it is important to recognize
that this is a type of melancholy which
you may treat at the time of the
diseases noticed by cutting open the
veins and draining blood until the
patient almost passes out let him be
washed in a sweet bath after rubbing him
down with milk whey for three days apply
a pumpkin south to him on the second and
third day following these cleansing --zz
anoint him with the antidote for viper
venom and do the rest of the things
prescribed for melancholy
when the disease has already come over
those who are accustomed to sleepwalking
anoint them with lotion and rub opium on
their ears and nostrils when they are
ready to sleep this video is brought to
you by Squarespace fantastic company to
use if you want to set up a website
looking forward to taking the first
steps toward voices of the past website
in the coming weeks and with an
easy-to-use interface and blogging and
social sharing features unlucky
Squarespace are here to help out as the
last time I attempted anything like this
was my myspace profile back in 2005 head
over to Squarespace calm for your free
trial and when you are ready to launch
go to Squarespace calm forward-slash
voices to get 10% off thanks the true
discourse declaring the damnable life
and death of one stub Peter a most
wicked sorcerer who and the likeness of
a wolf committed many murders continuing
this devilish practice 25 years killing
and devouring men women and children who
for the same fact was taken and executed
the 31st of October last in the town of
bed bar near the city of Cologne in
Germany truly translated out of the high
Dutch according to the copy printed in
cologne brought over to England by
George Bors the 11th day of this present
month of June 1590 who did both see and
hear the same in the towns of ser Alton
bed bar near into cologne in high
Germany there was continually brought up
and nourished one stub Peter who from
his youth was greatly inclined to evil
and the practicing of wicked arts even
from 12 years of age until 20 and so
forwards till his dying days the devil
saw him as a fit instrument to perform
mischief
wicked fiend pleased with the desire of
wrong and destruction gave unto him a
girdle which being put about him he was
straight transformed into the likeness
of a greedy devouring wolf strong and
mighty with eyes great and large which
in the night sparkled like unto brands
of fire a mouth great and wide with most
sharp and cruel teeth a huge body and
mighty paws and no sooner should he put
off the same girdle but presently he
should appear in his former shape
according to the proportion of a man as
if he had never been changed he
proceeded to the execution of sundry
most highness and vile murders for if
any person displeased him he would
thirst for revenge and no sooner should
they or any of theirs walk abroad in the
fields or about the city but in the
shape of a wolf he would present and
counter them and never rest till he had
plucked out their throats and tared
their joints asunder he would walk night
and day in the fields and work extreme
cruelty 'z and other times he would go
through the streets of Cologne bed burr
in conely habit and very civilly has one
known to the inhabitants there about and
oftentimes he saluted those whose
friends and children he had butchered
though nothing suspected for the same
thus continuing his devilish and
damnable deeds within the compass of a
few years he had murdered 13 young
children and two goodly young woman big
with child moreover he used many times
to kill arms and kids and such like
beasts feeding on the same as if he had
been a natural wolf indeed so that all
men mistrusted nothing less than this
his devilish sorcery while the young man
went on forward incontinent in the shape
and likeness of a wolf he encountered
his own son and their most cruelly slew
him the most monstrous act that
ever man heard of long time he continued
this vile and villainous life sometime
in the likeness of a wolf sometime in
the habit of a man sometime in the towns
and cities and sometimes in the woods
and thickets to them adjoining and
although they had practiced all the
means that men could devise to take this
ravenous beast yet until the Lord had
determined his fall they could not in
any way prevail in the end it pleased
God as they were in readiness and
provided to meet with him that they
should spy him in his wolfish likeness
at that time they beset him roundabout
and set their dogs upon him being hardly
pursued at the heels presently he
slipped his girdle from about him
whereby the shape of a wolf clean
avoided and he appeared presently in his
true shape and likeness having in his
hand a staff as worn walking through the
city for as much as they knew him to be
an ancient dweller in the town they came
unto Him and talking with him they
brought him by communication home to his
own house and finding him to be the man
indeed and no fantastical motion they
had him incontinent before the
magistrates to be examined thus being
apprehended he was shortly after put to
the rack in the town of bed burr but
fearing for the torture he voluntarily
confessed his whole life and made known
the villainies that he had committed for
the space of 25 years
thus gentle reader have I set down the
true discourse of this wicked man Stubb
Peter which I desire to be a warning to
all sorcerers and witches which
unlawfully follow their own devilish
imagination to the utter ruin and
destruction of their souls eternally
[Music]
Mahe poon a legitimate daughter -
Antoine poon a weaver of the late Jean
Poisson in the year 1765 and the
eleventh day of March
she was devoured at the place of malov
eat perish a fountain and at the front
door of her paternal house at three
hours after midday by a ferocious
anthropophaga saw animal whose name and
species have so far been unknown and
which has devoured many people in the
country of Javad on a viv array since
June of the year last 1764
it even has said that this ferocious
animal exerts its cruelty on small
children girls or slightly older women
preferably to vigorous man as it
probably considers the men better able
to defend themselves and resist them the
Bishop of menthe filled with zeal and
charity for these dire seasons ordered
in January of the present year 1765
public prayers throughout his diocese to
obtain from the mercy of God the
deliverance of this scourge the King
full of compassion for his subjects
promised a 6,000 pound gratuity to him
or those who managed to kill the animal
the states-general of the province of
language och standing in the city of
Montpellier Archbishop of Narbonne
presiding there also granted the sum of
two thousand pounds and the two
countries of Judah and Viv array jointly
awarded the sum of four hundred pounds
making the three a sum of eight thousand
four hundred to animate the courage of
those who will succeed in destroying the
ferocious animal and deliver us from it
since it continues to destroy the human
race
Marie poon a having been gnawed on both
thighs her abdomen Pierce and the face
pierced by the teeth of this cruel
animal was buried in the Fontan cemetery
the next day
mr. H twenty-year-old single unemployed
white male from Appalachia was admitted
with a history of long and chronic drug
abuse his present sickness came on while
in the United States Army ten months
previously
I felt himself slowly turning into a
werewolf seeing fur growing on his hands
and feeling it grow on his face he
experienced a sudden uncontrollable urge
to chase and devour live rabbits he also
felt that he had obtained horrible
insight into the devil's world after
having been in this condition for two
days he rejoined his army post but
remained convinced that he was a
werewolf that Eva closed he believed the
mess hall sign feeding time proved that
other people knew he was a wolf he was
sent to a psychiatrist who treated him
with glaucoma zine for a few months
during the next few months the patient
quit all drugs but continued to be
preoccupied by the werewolf
transformation he felt worse after he
saw the movie The Exorcist two weeks
prior to admission the MMPI was
interpreted as compatible with a an
acute schizophrenic or toxic psychosis
characterized by anxiety obsessional
thinking agitation and religious
delusions the patient was treated and
showed gradual improvement at the time
of his discharge 32 days after admission
he dropped the belief that he was a
werewolf or that he was possessed and
displayed no other overt psychotic
determinants no further contact was
established with this patient and it was
thought by the staff that he perhaps
felt threatened by the clinic attempts
to call him for further visits failed
you